the chance that you
the chance that you will die from eating
too much at McDonald's is about A
Thousand Times Higher and this is not an
external exaggeration this is statistics
it's about a thousand times higher than
the chance you'll be killed by some
Islamic State terrorism attack
so we are gaining the ability to bring
under our control
these uh huge problems again there are
still problems of course but most of
them when it comes to famine plague and
War are the result of human politics and
human incompetence not of human
ignorance if you again take famine
they'll no longer any natural famines in
the world only political famines if
somebody if a human being today on Earth
dies because they don't have enough to
eat in Syria or in North Korea or in
Somalia it's not because of natural
causes it's because some political
leader or government or ideology wants
them to starve to death so this is a new
phase in the history of the world we
have managed without any Divine help to
bring these three problems under our
control
and then the next question that the book
homodels asks is what next
so if we have solved or we are in the
process of solving these problems what
will we do with ourselves in the next
Century or two
and the book suggests that the next big
projects of humankind will be to
overcome old age and death
to find the keys the secret to happiness
and to basically upgrade humans into
Gods this is why the title homodeeos God
man
and I don't mean it as a kind of
literary metaphor
a minute in as in in the literal sense
that
for thousands of years humans have
imagined gods in a particular way they
ascribed particular abilities and
qualities to gods and we are here in a
church and the walls are full of these
descriptions of what God can do
and we are now seriously in the business
of acquiring these traditional Divine
abilities and qualities to ourselves
uh whether it's trying to overcome death
and gain immortality or whether it's
gaining the ability to create and design
life according to our wishes in the
Bible in the Book of Genesis basically
the first thing God does is to create
animals and plants and humans according
to his wishes we are now trying to gain
this Divine ability to ourselves it's
very likely that in the 21st century the
main product the most important products
of the human economy will no longer be
just vehicles and textiles and food and
weapons the main products will be bodies
and brains and Minds and in a way we are
even reaching beyond what ancient
religions ascribed to to the Gods
because the Gods like Jehovah in the
Bible they could create only organic
beings if you look if you're a
creationist and you look at the world so
all these animals all these plants God
created them and they are all organic
now humans are trying to do better than
that we will not just gain the ability
to create these organic beings that's
been around for 4 billion years we are
in the process of learning how to create
the fire the first inorganic entities
inorganic beings uh like artificial
intelligence that ever existed
so in this sense it's it's it's a
literal claim that humans are trying to
upgrade themselves into gods
now in order to do that
we'll have to turn our gaze from the
world outside to the world inside
the huge achievements of humankind in
the past especially the overcoming of
war and famine
has been the result of humans gaining
Mastery over the world outside over the
environment
um the next phase will involve trying to
gain Mastery over the world inside of
deciphering
um the human biochemistry our bodies our
brains learning how to re-engineer them
learning how to manufacture them this
will require a cooperation between the
life sciences on the one hand
and Computer Sciences on on the other
hand because this will require this
already requires
not just
uh breakthroughs in our understanding of
biology this will require a lot of
computing power there is no way that the
human brain
has the capacity by itself to decipher
the secrets to process the data that is
necessary to understand what's happening
inside you need help
from artificial intelligence you need
help from Big Data Systems
and this is what is happening already
today that we see this merger of the
biological sciences with computer
science
the result however
may not be the upgrading of humans into
Gods the result may be
the end of humanity because Humanity
will create something far more powerful
than itself once you have an artificial
intelligence or a big data system that
understands you better than you
understand yourself
then you're useless you're irrelevant
anything you can do this system can do
better
and
it's a distinct possibility it's not a
prophecy but it's the distinct
possibility that in the 21st century
most humans will therefore find
themselves in a new category in a new
class of of humanity
just as in the 19th century the
Industrial Revolution created a new
massive class of the urban working class
the proletariat and much of the
political and social history of the 19th
and 20th Century revolved around this
new working class
so the 21st century will create a new
massive class of useless people the
useless class
and maybe much of the social and
political history of the 21st century
revolve will revolve around the problems
and the hopes and the fears of this new
massive useless clause
so these are just some of the a short
outline of some of the main ideas I
might go back to predicting inflation in
three months uh shortly but okay there's
such a huge amount of ideas there but I
just wanted to kind of just rewind
slightly before we go into all these
issues about
um this new class of of of of of human
being or however we might describe it
yeah but when you when you set out on
sapiens your your your historic look at
um uh how uh Homo sapiens have developed
um uh through their history uh was it
always seen to you as a sort of two book
project so to speak and how much is
homadeus built on
Trends uh that you defined in
um uh sapiens because in sapiens you you
portray
um a world where homo sapiens
put themselves in a position of
dominance and at least part of your
argument for hermadeus appears to be
that this new supercategory of human
being Amadeus will put itself in a
dominant position given how Homo sapiens
have behaved in the past and you make
some links for example in the way that
homo sapiens
um deal with animal husbandry or don't
deal with animal husbandry to be to be
frank
what were the lessons from sapiens that
you drew out and built into the
hermadeus work
well first of all I when I started
safety and said no idea I will even have
one book uh let alone two
um homework deals is a direct
continuation or former say of sapiens
but it really kind of wrote itself
because I was giving all these
interviews and all these talks and I'm a
historian I really like the past but the
vast majority of the questions were
about the future
now people say okay the past but what
will happen now that we you told us
about these 70 000 units what will
happen next so this well most of the
questions and most of the requests for
interviews and and talks uh wanted me to
speculate about the future so from
interview to interview and article to
article uh homodeeos started uh to take
shape and it is definitely built on the
foundations on the ideas of of sapiens
in particular
sapiens of the book
the main thesis there is that what
enabled human beings to conquer the
planet and to turn themselves from
insignificant Apes into the masters of
the planet is their ability to cooperate
in large numbers which in turn is
founded on their ability to create
fictions and spread them around and
believe in them at the basis of all
large-scale human cooperation you always
find some fictional story whether it's
about God or about the nation or about
human rights or about money there is
always fiction at the basis
and what I'm trying to do it in
homoderos is see what happens when these
mythologies these fictions meet
god-like technologies that for the first
time make it possible to start realizing
the myth not after you die in some
fantastic heaven but here on Earth with
the help of Technology I'm again I'm a
historian I come my background in the in
the humanities I'm a terrible
technophobe I hardly know how to turn on
the television I have to rely on my
husband to do that
um and so I'm not really interested in
the in the technical aspects of big data
or artificial intelligence I just take
it for granted okay it can artificial
intelligence will soon be able to drive
a car by itself don't you need to be
don't you need to be some people in the
AI Market or in AI research would maybe
argue that the problem with Interlopers
coming in who don't know about
technology and not quite sure how to
turn the TV on is that how can they make
sensible predictions about what AI may
or may not do for human beings and to
human beings I think more importantly
but that's a problem for a historian to
come in and make such big bold
predictions on an area that they're not
actually specifically expert in
well I had rely on the experts and what
is interesting what is vital for me is
to try and understand from the experts
what is or isn't possible to do with
these kinds of Technologies how is not
within my field of expertise and if you
try to cover everything it's impossible
you have to give up something I think
most of the people who are very
interested in the future of technology
they are experts in technology so they
understand uh these technical aspects of
biotechnology or genetic engineering or
artificial intelligence but for me the
most interesting questions are not the
technical ones they are the political
ones the economic ones the philosophical
ones and how can you make sense of what
artificial intelligence would do to the
economy or would do to religion if you
don't have the necessary background in
philosophy in history
um I think this is much more important
to take an analogy from a past
technology nuclear weapons you don't
really need to know how a nuclear bomb
Works maybe there is a demon inside how
what do I care I mean what is important
for me is that this device somehow don't
ask me how this device I know can
obliterate a city and kill hundreds of
thousands of people in a minute this is
important to know how and and this
building on that you can start thinking
about what this kind of weapon might
mean for geopolitics or for religion
how does it work is not so important